there's an unspoken rule amongst youtube
creators that inevitably whatever videos
you hate most that you put the least
effort into are going to be your most
popular and whichever videos you love
the most or mean the most to you
personally are inevitably just not going
to do
as well and this is
kind of true in many respects
uh i've definitely found that many of my
personal favorite projects have gone a
little bit under the radar comparatively
that's fine but that is why we are here
doing something a little bit different
going through
some of my most popular videos and why i
hate them with
a tier list because people people
freaking love tearless don't they uh so
we've got five ranks with the bottom
being killer with fire and then if
they're so bad kill it with fire then
kill me and before we get started i
would love for you to tell me which
videos meant the most to you that i've
made or which ones keep you into the
channel or that you like the most where
do you where do you come from you know
tell me down below in the comments uh so
we're gonna start with my hello hello
mamo
momo would apparently like to um
to to join us as we um as we rank these
videos
uh so
number one
number one we're gonna start with my
most popular video which is
actually an exception to what i was
talking about before it's the psychology
of azula video now i actually i actually
quite like this video still it's one of
those rare occasions where i put a lot
of effort into something
and uh it actually paid off you know it
it's still a pretty solid video it moved
a lot of people i i really like it and i
was very proud of it in the end when i
first edited it i ended over three days
and i think i had about three to four
hours sleep each night because i was
determined to hit my weekly deadline so
i'm actually going to put it in this tip
despite the fact despite the fact that
it has since come out that i got a
couple of things wrong in my studies
i did consult with people who knew
psychology a lot better than i did uh
but i didn't happen to pick it up turns
out i got a bit mixed up in the
definitions of sociopath and psychopath
it doesn't derail the whole video but
it's it's still irritating because it's
one of those things i'm gonna keep
getting comments on uh
now
secondly let's let's go with is
toothless a titan wing
okay so
if you didn't know i used to do how to
train your dragon videos yeah you know
that that old series yeah i used to do
videos on that uh because it was
something i was mildly interested in and
it happened to take off and there was an
audience waiting for videos like that
and um it worked
ah but um
um hey sup fury at the end of the second
toothless face hey sub theory
hey sub furies yeah so
um i used to start off my videos with a
phrase
hey subfuries because one time someone
sent me an email uh and it was a very
nice email from a young girl and and she
said you're your sub fury in brackets
subscriber night fury her name and i was
like oh there's a perfect name because i
was looking for a name to call people in
my audience and this was their
subscribers and their night furies
that's their favorite dragon who doesn't
want to be a dragon so i was going i'm
going to call you all
subfuries
brilliant i'm a genius
and
inevitably
because these things happen
my audience expanded and suddenly people
who didn't know what night furies were
they thought i was saying hey submissive
furry
[Music]
and i didn't know what to do because i
was like i can't i can't stop calling
them that but also i don't you know i
don't lose there but also i can't call
them
furries
man i look so young i look so childish
here
wow ah yeah and not only that like all
of my old videos made me cringe because
of this i i was incapable of being on
camera i did not know how to be on
camera i didn't i was not comfortable
with it i did not i did not feel
at home
and you can tell you can tell let's just
play a bit of the video wildebeest he
breaks out of his cage of ice his
nostrils flaring and glowing and he
challenges its position as the alpha of
all dragons the dragons all swoop around
so that happened uh
so uh naturally i'm gonna
stick that and kill it with fire it's
not the worst it is not
it is not the worst next up
would you believe that my fastest
growing video
ever
was not about writing was not about
world building was not about avatar it
was not about lord of the rings it was
marvel
this has always been a sore point for me
i took part in this this this
event called one marvelous scene when
avengers in game or infinity war dropped
and i made a video um
about iron man and mental illness and it
was a pretty low effort video i didn't
think that much about it
uh but it got like
700 000 views in the space of a couple
of days which is easily the fastest
growing video i have ever had
and i kind of hate it i kind of hate
that i'm like
it's a part of my channel's history
and i can't change it and it's really
funny because i was taking part of it
amongst a whole bunch of other comic
book um focused superhero focused
channels led by nandome movies and it
was the fastest growing video out of the
entire list and i feel like i don't
deserve that i did not deserve that and
the whole reason was because i happened
to call the video
i am iron man and you know what happens
at the end of avengers end game
that's right yeah so i kind of hate this
it's not terrible video but it is very
low effort i don't think it looks very
good i don't think the script is that
good i don't think it's particularly
profound i felt was pretty
hamvested together so i'm gonna do
another kill it with fire okay
what everyone gets wrong about bending
this was this was an avatar video where
i discussed basically people get really
caught up on
you know oh can
is is stone
is like it's like plant bending a thing
is wood bending a thing can can an air
bender uh control sound because you know
it's all about traveling through the air
and whatever and i and i always hated
those questions because
the the the elements are psychospiritual
you know they're philosophical water
doesn't heal because healing is you know
because water naturally heals because
it's a material molecular part of heal
of water it it heals because spiritually
and philosophically we've always
associated water with health and um and
healing
um and there's a lot of links to to
things like reiki and and and
and stuff like that uh so i actually do
really like this video and i'm glad that
it's one of my most popular ones funnily
enough it actually got to 300 000 views
which was stunning for me at the time um
before it got claimed and it got blocked
and i had to re-upload the video
slightly differently and then i was i
was afraid that it wouldn't do well and
it did it did well again so i'm going to
put this one innate here actually
on writing
hard magic systems this is one of those
videos where it's it's foundational to
the channel it was my first educational
video and i remember telling my
girlfriend i was like this is gonna get
10 000 views it is not going to do well
i know it's a waste of time but i've had
a good period i'm going to try something
new
and i was stoked when it got hundreds of
thousands of views within the space of a
few days and that
brought my whole channel into a new era
and more importantly i was suddenly
feeling like i was doing something good
you know like i wasn't just talking
about nerdy stuff
uh that would be eventually forgotten
that that it doesn't really change
people's lives
uh
education is a really important part of
my channel
and i felt like i finally felt found
something that was like really
personally meaningful
at the same time uh it's a pretty cheesy
video
and again guess what it starts with
hey subfuries fantasy styles are known
for a lot of
things um
so
there's the cheesiness and then there's
the foundationalness which puts it
strictly middle of the road but because
it is so important and it has brought so
many people to the channel i'm gonna be
i'm gonna be generous towards it and put
it in a tier
is glass bending possible it's strictly
middle of the road we're going to put
that in bed here let's let's go with iro
and the spirit world
you
cannot
fathom
how much i hate this video
it is my most popular theory video i
ever made
and it is
terrible
it is not something that someone who is
in any way coherently minded
that is
sapient that has any
degree of ability to reason to look at
the evidence and facts and draw
reasonable conclusions from to
understand reality in any sort of
grounded way
that
any person who has any sort
of
connection with reality
would believe or would make
and yet it is my video and i am that
person
this theory
falls apart at the slightest scrutiny it
falls apart if you look at even the
mildest cursory evidence beyond what i
show in the video
it is based on purely circumstantial
speculation at best and clearly was not
intended and has so many holes that you
could not fill
water with it
that one fell apart but you know what
i'm saying it's always been a big
question how did iro get into the spirit
world and
come on the obvious answer is he was
just so spiritual that he ascended
basically he reached nirvana of some
kind and that is the simplest clearest
best explanation but i was like no
i've got to come up with a better idea
and i was like he's half spirit because
he has part of a spirit inside of him
and it's a spirit fox
and it just doesn't make any sense
and i know why i did this i did this
because
back in the day at the start of my
channel i stuck to a weekly upload
schedule religiously rigidly i would not
miss an upload even if that meant
uploading a bad video you know
and what it means that if i was stumped
for ideas if i didn't have time because
you know i was i was writing filming and
editing and i had uni and a job at the
same time if i didn't
manage to get something together
then i'd usually do something that was
just
good at grabbing eyes that was good at
that i knew people would click on this
is a consequence of that this is a
consequence of me going uh everyone
wants to know the answer to the question
here's a quickly thrown together theory
so i hate it i hate it because of the
way it came about i hate it because it's
a bad theory i hate it because it
doesn't look good i hate it because it
has hazel furies at the beginning
uh and it's made even worse by the fact
that less than a month later i came up
with an even better theory that
there's a lot of evidence to suggest
that the dragons in the avatar world are
potentially part spiritual or from the
spirit world and he has a clearly
distinct connection to the dragon so if
you wanted to go with that you could do
he's half dragon
so not only did i do a terrible theory
but i did the worst version of a
terrible theory that you could make
so
kill it with fire then kill me
um okay
the last airbender is the worst film
ever made here's why i actually really
like this video it's
it it still sticks with me because
it's
it it was a lot of effort it was the
biggest project i've ever done but it
definitely paid off um in terms of
building the channel
and
i people still find it really funny i it
still looks pretty good
and but i think the big part of it is
that i i often get so wrapped up in
trying to be deep and meaningful and say
something that matters you know
uh this was a real release it was a real
time for me to just sort of let loose
and be a meme you know it's playing on a
10 year old meme within the avatar
community now you know 13 year old meme
i guess
uh that quote film that shyamalan made
and
as a result i was just really relaxed i
was having fun i wasn't too worried
about you know
being concise and making sure everyone
gets every little detail that i'm
talking about
and but people still found it insightful
so you know what i'm still really proud
of that one i deserve another risk too
uh
okay the the the why kill the avatar
that's in a similar boat to the whole on
riding hard magic systems video it's
foundational it was my first video essay
uh but it was still pretty cheesy uh so
we're gonna we're gonna go pretty mixed
and we're just gonna go b all right
so
what happened to azula
now
this is one of those easy videos where i
literally just took the comics and
summarized them basically
but i really hate this video or at least
i hated it a lot more until
six months ago and i'll explain why the
video is not that insightful it feels
cheap uh the discussions aren't that
interesting people obviously watched it
um but yeah uh
no the real reason that i hated it for a
long time was the sponsorship
now
here's kind of a bit of a darker side to
the youtube sponsorship thing that you
guys might not know about but
thing is
when you're doing this job you have no
idea how much your video is worth to
sponsors to advertisers tv and and film
and and stuff like that like radio
they've got rates worked out they know
how much their stuff is worth there's
research they've done especially in big
industries where you've got people who
know this sort of thing when you're
starting out you have no idea how much
you should be paid for this sort of
thing and so companies 100 take
advantage of that i have an email up on
my on my on my screen right now which is
basically saying you know we send you
a free item and you you you advertise it
on a video for us now strictly speaking
they're trying to rip me off okay and
when i was really small i was contacted
by this company called seismic so if you
ever get contacted by seismic this is
what they're doing all right
they offer you a certain amount of money
and they take a cut
but they don't tell you how much of a
cut that they're going to take
and i only found out a lot later on that
they took
50
of the money that they were actually
offered by the company 50 percent which
is
radically exploitative it's awful and if
they did it to me they're doing it to a
million other people and i know that
that sort of thing
um
but
because you're so small you don't want
to lose the sponsorship you don't want
to feel like you know
because
it's still a massive amount of money you
know they're offering they offered me i
think fifteen hundred dollars
and that to me was like a huge amount of
money for a sponsorship my goodness
and
i didn't know that i was i was being
ripped off way more than that but
because you don't want to lose that
sponsorship you want to do the best job
that you can and they pressure you to do
that they say we want you to do a
two-minute integration where you say
these specific things where we approve
the video they want a lot more creative
control than they really should be
having you know the sponsorship should
really just be this is sponsored by them
hey here's what they do at the end of
the video but they kind of tricked me
into doing an almost two and a half
minute advert at the beginning and i got
a lot of backlash for that from the
community and i hated it the more i
looked at it i tried to be creative with
it but obviously it's still an advert
and for a company that i didn't really
understand
and so i intensely regretted that video
for a long time and after a while
i edited that out that sponsorship out
now technically there was breaking
contract but what are they gonna do
they're not working with me anymore
anyway
um
and so yeah you can't see the
sponsorship anymore but it was there so
i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna put it in the
spirit of that and kill it with fire but
because it's removed it's not kill it
with fire then kill me
the fire nation a study in word building
this is an ongoing series that i've had
for years i think i did the first one
like
three years ago and then i did the earth
kingdom two years ago and then i just
did the air nomads and people being like
you're gonna finish the series right uh
and one person was like why didn't you
do the water tribes just actually never
got around to it did you see it only
three years through the first three
either way i actually still really like
this video it's not perfect but i think
the discussion's really interesting
around the the industrial revolution and
fire nation so i'm actually going to put
it in an 80 it's not perfect but it's
fine uh same on running power escalation
i think it's a really good solid example
of
of of an on writing video just the style
uh i try to be kind of funny a little
bit quite accessible
but educational and and specific
um
i think it's got quite a few good
examples of that so
you know looking at this layout at the
moment you you wouldn't believe that
like you would hate your videos that
much but i suppose putting it in these
terms
it's kind of like
uh
it's kind of like you focus you hyper
fixate on the stuff that you hate you
hyper fixate it on on on the things that
that you think are really bad
representations of your work
i know that i do that people tend like
people do tell me i'm a bit of a
pessimist or or hyper fixation or bad
things
sometimes
so he's trying
uh let me visualize it all right what
happened to zuko's mother now if i
remember rightly this was my first
avatar video
and i hate it
it is horrifically cheesy
um
it is it is
it it's it's
let's have a watch
hey people of the present so you know
how to train your dragon video will be
coming out in just a few days but today
we'll be
look how young i am
where's the beard boy where's the beard
well at least you got hair fun fact back
at the very beginning i i didn't have
lighting obviously lighting was
incredibly expensive
and so i had a
uh window i think to my to my left there
and i had
a light up on the ceiling which i had
taped a piece of paper hanging down from
between me and the light to diffuse the
light otherwise it was too harsh and too
bright that's where you can see the
light coming in
from the side here like that it was my
attempt to create just kind of like
soft natural lighting on zero budget
uh the video is terrible uh it's a
horrible summary of what happened i
don't know i i thought that people
wanted short videos for some reason it
was just a terrible summary it did not
give the entire full story it's
horrifically cheesy i think i got a
couple of facts wrong at points um
and it
it's it's just
i would do a way better job of
discussing
the story
now
and there's always that element of it
that you look at your stuff and and
you're not necessarily comparing it to
what you could have done at the time
you're looking at what you would do now
and i hate it because like i it's just
so much worse um
it has got me 1.3 million views so you
know thank you uh so we're gonna but um
i do hate it with a fiery passion so
we're gonna put it in kill kill it with
fire then kill me
ah all right how arpa died
i
do not like this video
uh for the same reason that i don't like
the the the ira in the spirit world
video it was one of those videos where i
was running out of time and i didn't
know what to do and i was just like crap
i don't know i don't know and so i was
just like how appetized how appetite
okay how did upper die we don't know we
don't know we have no data on it we have
no information at all on it let's just
make something up and my argument
if i remember rightly is like he's kind
of like a manatee
and
and also a like a cow
and if you put together an average out
there ages he probably died around the
same year that aang died
and it's just it doesn't make it because
it's like he could have still died
any other time there's no evidence that
sky bison's age
like last that same amount as the
animals they're based on
and he could have died years before or
years after anyway
uh
it it's just a terrible theory it was
the product of time pressure but
apparently people wanted to watch it
some reason thank you if you did
uh
but it's again it's just it's just a
representation of of like me running out
of time and panicking so we're gonna go
kill it with fire then kill me
hard versus soft world building now
this
this is a bit of a complicated one
because
i worked really hard on this video with
a friend of mine uh
ellie gordon
she is a kind of a creator and writer
and animator
and we had long been talking about how
we were kind of missing the magical
fantasy the the unexplainable the
mysterious the bigger than us fantasy
and a lot of fantasy these days was very
grounded and and
and
uh
explainable
um and he's sort of stripped of it of
its mystery
but we were trying to come up with a
theory or a discussion around those
types of stories and we settled on hard
versus soft world building playing on
kind of the brandon sanderson hard hard
magic soft magic and this hard science
fiction hearts soft science fiction so
hard
hard soft
little and here's the thing the core
thesis
is good the core thesis is something i
absolutely stand by
but it is a complicated topic and i
think that i didn't quite articulate
some of the nuances of what i was
talking about that well
so when i went and wrote this chapter
into on writing we're building volume 2
which if you haven't got you should pick
it up um i rewrote it i rewrote it with
with a ton more references you can see
all that you've got marzipan by emmy
bender norska in the valley of the wind
castle on the sky um
dark salt the dark souls series
annihilation by jeff and me of the near
series um nightfall by isaac asimov
like i i i rewrote the the script and
the thesis to i think be a bit more
well-rounded
um to include a bit more of those
details and that detail can be seen in
the
four examples of soft word building um
so core thesis good
the specific examples themselves i think
needed a bit of work and so i'm really
proud of it because ellie and i actually
introduced a term that is used online
now i've seen it used on reddit and on
twitter not really referencing me but
people being like this is a good example
of soft world building and i really i
really like that um
it's something that i'm proud of to have
contributed to the educational discourse
in that way so this is actually this is
actually an s tier for me personally it
feels like a real achievement um
yeah
all right
rewriting the night king uh so this is
this is basically one of the few times
that i have hopped on a bandwagon i'm
not very good at following trends
following you know very like super
famous trains things when they're
happening arcane and squid game came out
at the end of last year and it wasn't
until like
now that i put out a video about it
but game of thrones ended big big huge
thing
and um everyone had a lot of complicated
thoughts i know i certainly did and i've
always been fascinated with rewrites
i've always loved watching rewrites and
trying to figure out like oh would that
be better would that have worked better
i think nando v movies did this quite
well with some of the the dc films and
the marvel films he introduced one small
change and it would usually improve the
the the story a lot
um
and so i watched the final season of
game of thrones and i was disappointed
in many ways it did not go the way i
thought it would um and not that that's
a bad thing but that it didn't go in a
way that i feel answered the questions
the narrative actually set up
um and so i looked for a way to rewrite
that and i did two videos on it i did
one video rewriting the end of the night
king and one video rewriting the end of
the series itself and this video really
annoys me because
it did really really well but of those
two videos
of the one
it's definitely the worst one i don't
think this rewrite is particularly
strong i don't think this rewrite is
that great
i think it's fine it's a bit more
functional than the episode we got but
it's nothing special it's nothing
spectacular and if i wrote it i wouldn't
be that proud of it in the first place
it was trying to work with what we had
in that one episode i guess but i could
have done a better job and i really wish
that those those views went into the end
of the season rewrite
because
that to me is actually quite solid it is
a way that i feel answers a lot of
questions and does it in a really
interesting way in a time efficient
manner with some creative decisions so
again it's one of those things where
it's like why did you have to watch this
one why couldn't you watch the other one
and you get that all the time if you're
gonna if you're a creator you're gonna
you're gonna find yourself kind of
keeping on coming back to that
so
i'm i'm gonna put it in
in b
just cause i'm
no you know what kill it with fire
because i i really don't like it that
much how did legend of cory get from
this level of technology to this so how
was it basically medieval in in the last
airbender and then industrial 1920s uh
legend of korra
this is the iconic example for me of
people commenting before they watch the
video i cannot explain how every single
day i get more comments of people going
how is it that hard to believe they they
we went from flight to space in 60 years
you just need to think about the real
world
uh how can you be so dumb and
it's annoying
because
that is the video i'm not doubting it
i'm explaining it to other people who
were doubting it
and it's like i know you didn't watch
the video i laid out a timeline for it
um so that is frustrating
uh and sometimes there are just
frustrating videos which it's not
because the video is bad it's because of
the response or like the place that it
occupies that you come to hate it but
it's not it's not terrible video so i'm
just gonna put it in b
uh all right
soft
magic systems are better and here's why
this
is a complicated one okay
this one this one's a complicated one i
don't know where
it should sit
i really don't because
the reason i made this video
i actually i've always wanted to talk
about soft magic and why i prefer it
that that was
that was true
but i had the 2020 charity livestream
coming up and i hadn't promoted it and i
was really worried uh because no one was
going to watch it no one was going to
donate no one knew was even happening
and i i hadn't had the time to quickly
promote it like i had done in the um
years before
and so i was like crap i need i need a
video that's moving that is uh popular
um
and that will push people to the the
dairy livestream and so i i fell back on
magic systems is popular
two mental illness is moving three the
the uh the the video is the the cherry
livestream is about mental illness and i
was like great
good
so
the problem was
because i was throwing together a video
with that intention behind it
that intention really came first that
intention really came before the content
of the video
and i i know i knowingly twisted my
argument to push towards the charity
live stream and like yeah it's for a
good cause but it's still frustrating
for me because i didn't actually
articulate the argument i think as
strongly as i could or in the way that i
would necessarily like to expand on it
so you'll probably get another video in
the future of me talking about soft
magic systems but like the focus on
mental illness and life is strange uh i
don't think was the strongest take that
i could i could have on it uh and again
the the soft magic is better kind of
comes out in the soft world building
videos and the hard stuff we're learning
about the strengths of that it's deeply
connected to that theory
uh
so yeah it's it's warped by that by that
aim that i had
uh and that's frustrating so it it's an
okay video i wish i could like put it in
between b and kill it with fire
but
i'm gonna put it at kill the fire
because even though i like the sentiment
i'm frustrated by the fact that i
weakened my own argument to to do
something and that's that's annoying
last video
uh
the philosophy
of uncle iro
i could have done a way better job on
this
it's just the reality it's a fine video
um
but focusing on masculinity in the way
that i did i
i feel like it's a lot bigger than that
i feel like his his ideas are a lot
bigger than that
and i think it was a solid argument for
the most part
um
but i wish that i expanded on it and i
wish they didn't sort of use the
philosophy of uncle iro so flippantly in
there it's it's a good it's a good video
it's functional it's fine but it's one
of those ones with so many little things
that i wish i kind of expanded on that i
wish i added in uh that it feels
incomplete now looking back at it and i
wish i got that i i i kind of regret
that
a lot of these videos it all comes down
to i wish i did it differently you know
and so it's not terrible so i'm gonna
put it in
in b
so
this was
a lot of my
videos all right this was a lot of my
most popular videos and looking at it
like this and relatively even spread
slightly weighted towards the bottom
um
it kind of makes me realize ah maybe my
videos aren't all terrible
which is a good thing for me to keep in
mind because as i said i'm known for
being a bit negative about my work i
tend to focus on the things that are bad
the things that need to be fixed rather
than the things that are going well
so
that's something i need to work on
and looking at this that's good i can
look at this stuff and i can go you know
what i've done well
i've done well
it's easy to get caught up in like
wishing that your best projects like my
video or mental illness are your most
popular projects but at the same time
this this
these videos i am proud of many of these
like a lot of these i feel i have
contributed something real to the world
uh even though there are also ones where
i feel i've contributed something bad to
the world as well
well this was a lot of fun i i hope you
enjoyed it as well do you think i'm
wrong about my own videos probably
because i i don't know how to judge my
own work anymore
anyways stay nerdy and i'll see you in
the future